fête nationale 1965 en pleine révolution
tranquille
c'est à ce moment là que le gouvernement
lesage dote le québec de ce nouvel outil
laquelle sera appelée à devenir
réservoir considérable de capitaux pour
être plus précis la caisse aura deux
vocations d'un côté gérer et faire
fructifier les rentes des québécois
c'est ce qui lui vaut son surnom de bas
de laine de l'autre investir dans les
différents secteurs de l'économie
l'immobilier l'énergie ce qui en fait le
bras financier du gouvernement
quand la caisse a été créé on tablait
sur 2 milliards d'actifs en 1976 4
milliards en 86 l'augmentation sera
beaucoup plus rapide
on atteint 227 milliards de dollars
juste avant la crise financière de 2008
heureux d'apprendre la direction
d'organisations qui est en excellente
santé financière
la présidence de richard guay sera
marquée par la pire performance de
l'histoire de la caisse 40 milliards
partis dans les tourbillons de la crise
financière et du papier commercial
un produit qui s'est avéré bien trop
risqué l'ancien président henri paul
rousseau en prendra la responsabilité en
2015 la caisse se diversifient un peu
plus en créant une filiale dédiée aux
infrastructures
c'est cette division cdpq infra qui
chapeaute notamment l'immense chantier
dure m le projet de transport le plus
important des 50 dernières années au
québec
au total neuf présidents tous des hommes
vont se succéder à la tête de la caisse
dans le portefeuille que charles aimons
récupère il ya aujourd'hui plus de 300
milliards de dollars
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal